tout ne va pas si bien pour les 33
mineurs chiliens bloqués depuis 22 jours
à 700 m sous terre la première vidéo les
montré hier en forme optimiste mais cinq
d'entre eux souffrent de dépression
annoncée hier soir le gouvernement
chilien les opérations de sauvetage
elles débuteront demain ou lundi que
gilbert malgré la détermination les
sourires affichés
certains des 33 mineurs chiliens coincés
sous la terre commence à perdre le moral
sur cette vidéo diffusée il ya deux
jours seule la moitié d'entre eux
apparaît les autres souffrent de
dépression après plus de trois semaines
par 35 degrés à 700 mètres de profondeur
les secours ont déjà organisé pour cinq
mineurs d entretien à distance avec un
psychiatre marc ela ce sont les plus
isolées ils n'ont pas voulu apparaître
sur la vidéo il ne s'alimentent pas bien
aujourd'hui nous allons nous concentrer
sur eux question est le terme qui
convient
grâce aux vivres et en médicaments
acheminés par une sonde
leur état général s'est néanmoins
améliorée au dessus d'eux à l'air libre
les proches s'installe pour une longue
attente entre espoir et résignation
c'est désespérant de ne rien pouvoir
faire pour eux on exprime tous le
sentiment pour on veut les aider à
garder la foi elle me demande de
vérifier que sa fille s'est classé
devoir il s'inquiète beaucoup pour elle
il m'a demandé de l'épouser et j'ai dit
oui les mineurs captifs vont bénéficier
des conseils d'experts de la nasa
habitué au confinement dans l'espace
mais pour cet homme d'église c'est aussi
la foi qui sauve g33 bible le renvoyer
par la sonde elles pour leur apporter un
soutien spirituel
les travaux de sauvetage commenceront
vraiment demain ou lundi
un excavateur de 30 tonnes doit forer un
conduit de 700 m de long et 66 cm de
large
il faudra attendre trois ou quatre mois
avant de pouvoir extraire les mineurs de
leur piège souterrain